.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Originalkommentar)
Auch einen Tag nach dem Tod
von Prinzessin Diana
bei einem Verkehrsunfall in Paris
steht die Weltöffentlichkeit
noch unter Schock.
* Handy *
Hallo?
Ich komme um 7 Uhr Kaffee trinken.
70 Mio., Mann!
Überfall! Komm raus aus dem Wagen,
habe ich gesagt!
Ja, der 1. September 1997
wird mir in Erinnerung bleiben.
Keine Bewegung! Überfall!
Alle auf den Boden!
Nach einem solchen Fall
ist niemand mehr derselbe.
Keine Bewegung!
- Okay! Einsteigen!
Warte, warte, warte!
* Reifenquietschen *
(Radio) 53 Mio. Fr. in bar.
So was
hat die Schweiz noch nie gesehen.
Nicht mal meine Verhaftung
war normal.
(Radio)
Von den Räubern fehlt jede Spur.
Fast wie im Film.
Es ist der Postraub des Jahrhunderts.
Ich habe damals für "10vor10"
manchmal über
den Fraumünster-Postraub berichtet.
Einmal sass ich
bei der Gerichtsverhandlung
und sah die Männer
nebeneinander sitzen:
immer einen Räuber
und einen Polizisten.
Sie sahen einander vom Alter her
sehr ähnlich.
Sie hatten ähnliche Frisuren.
Und während der Verhandlung
überlegte ich mir:
"Woran liegt es,
dass der eine Polizist ist
und der andere ein Räuber?"
Dieser Frage ging ich nach.
Und? Hat dir der Film gefallen?
- Ja, total, v.a. die Autoszene.
Er ist fast so gut gefahren wie ich.
- Er sieht auch aus wie du.
Findest du?
- Ja.
Das dachte ich auch,
als ich ihn sah.
Wenn ich er bin,
kannst du Frau Bond sein.
Äh ... Nein, wenn ...
Wenn, dann bin ich Jane Bond.
Jane Bond?
- Ja.
Und ich dein Chauffeur, dein Fahrer?
Wie immer?
- Dream-Team.
Ein Dream-Team?
Hey ...
- Ja?
Ich will ... äh ...
dass du weisst ...
... dass ich dich sehr mag.
Und egal, was passiert:
Vergiss das nie, okay?
* Sanfte Musik *
Hast du etwas verbrochen?
Natürlich nicht, aber ...
Morgen Miami, Toronto, James Bond.
Tomorrow never dies, oder?
Wir sehen uns heute Abend.
- Ja, ist gut.
Okay?
- Ja.
Ich denke, dass ich
ein normaler junger Mann war.
Ich besuchte die Discos.
Ich spielte Billard.
Ich war immer gegen Gewalt.
Alles gut?
Aber mit etwa 20, 21 lernte ich ...
äh ... Leute kennen ...
Ähm ...
Aber diese Leute
waren nicht unbedingt heilig.
Ich hätte diese Leute
sofort erkennen
und mich von ihnen entfernen müssen.
Ciao, Nock!
Wie geht's? Gut? Super!
Ciao, Bella! Wie geht's?
- Ciao!
Danke! Hey, Amigo! Alles gut?
Damals arbeitete ich im Spielsalon.
Ich zeige dir nächstes Mal,
wie es geht.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit. Ciao!
Elias war ein Kunde. Und eine Frage,
die ich nicht vergessen kann:
"Was würdest du
für eine Million machen?"
Ich schaue ihm in die Augen.
Und dann sage ich:
"Elias, für eine Million
bringe ich dich um."
Hallo?
- Andrea?
Ja. Ist das Elias?
- Ja.
Ich sage Andrea zu dir, ist gut?
- Ja, ist gut.
Ähm ... Du hast mir ja geschrieben,
du wollest für den Film aussagen,
wie das mit dem Postraub war.
Ist das gut für dich?
Kannst du jetzt reden?
Ja, kein Problem.
Mit Elias Al Abdullah,
dem Boss dieser Bande,
hatte ich während der ganzen Zeit
nie die Möglichkeit gehabt zu reden.
Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Es hatte sich nicht ergeben.
Und jetzt habe ich für diesen Film
nochmals versucht,
mit ihm Kontakt aufzunehmen
und er fand dann,
jetzt sei der Moment gekommen,
jetzt wolle er erzählen, wie es war.
Und dass ich vieles
heute anders sehe.
Okay! Kannst du mir beschreiben,
wo du gerade bist?
Ja, ich bin in einem Raum.
Wir sind neun Personen.
Wir sind alles politische Gefangene.
Wir haben ein grosses Urteil
bekommen.
Aber ich möchte jetzt am Telefon
lieber nicht darüber reden.
Okay! Aber wieso
kannst du überhaupt telefonieren?
Wieso?
Na ja, eigentlich
ist Telefonieren verboten.
Aber in diesem Gefängnis
sind 1'200 Personen.
Von diesen 1'200 Personen
haben 900 ein Telefon.
Du bezahlst die Wächter
und bekommst ein Telefon.
* Elias lacht. *
Okay!
Dann machen wir vorwärts, bevor
die Verbindung wieder vorbei ist.
Der erste Moment, in dem
der Postraub in deinen Kopf kam:
Wie war das?
Ja, das war ... äh ...
Das war 1996.
Ich war jung und stark.
Ich wollte Spass haben und so.
Und ich war viel
in der Dago-Bar in Seebach.
Ende 1996, Anfang 1997 kam der Chef
der Dago-Bar zu mir und sagte,
er kenne Marcello,
der bei der Post arbeite.
Dort sei viel Geld.
Und er wolle etwas machen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich arbeitete seit zwei Jahren
in der Fraumünsterpost.
Ich war so eine Art Hilfsarbeiter.
Und ich hatte nicht viel Lohn.
Ragazzi, buona serata! A domani!
Ciao, Romana! Tutto bene?
Aspetta!
Ich helfe dir.
Wo muss der hin?
- Hinten zur vier.
Ich mache das für dich. Komm!
Danke!
- Ciao, cara!
Ciao!
Ich liess mir nichts anmerken.
Ich war immer freundlich.
Aber eigentlich war ich
mit meinem Leben nicht zufrieden.
Ich habe mich bei der Polizeischule
in Italien beworben,
aber da wollte man mich nicht.
Es waren so viele Bewerber.
Und ich hatte Probleme
mit der Sprache.
Ich ging sieben Jahre lang
in der Schweiz zur Schule.
Dann sieben Jahre in Italien.
Und mit 14
kam ich wieder in die Schweiz.
Irgendwie ...
... hatte ich alles falsch gemacht.
Den Traumjob bekam ich nicht.
Und ich hatte Schulden,
wegen des Unfalls.
Ich musste sogar für den Baum,
in den ich hineingefahren war,
500 Fr. bezahlen.
Und dann brauchte ich auch Geld
für ein neues Auto.
Ich musste
auch für die Rallyes üben.
Das war mein zweiter Traum:
eine Karriere als Rallyefahrer.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Ich fing an, zusätzlich
zu meinem Job bei der Post
in einer Szenenbeiz zu putzen -
morgens vor der Arbeit bei der Post.
(Rolf Jäger) In Zürich gab es damals
wirklich enorm viel Gewalt
in der Stadt.
Heute ist das völlig anders.
Zürich ist eine strahlende Stadt.
Die 90er-Jahre waren ja die Jahre
der offenen Drogenszene.
Sehr viel war durch die Drogenszene
auch in Unordnung.
* Düstere Musik *
Alle nach hinten!
Hände hinter den Kopf!
Es beelendete einen
in den 90er-Jahren auch,
wenn Sie dies in dieser Intensität
auch beruflich immer mitbekamen.
Da passte dieser Postraub
sehr gut ins Bild.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Der Besitzer der Dago-Bar
hatte gesagt,
ich solle alles vorbereiten ...
... und mich dann
mit einem Elias treffen.
* Düstere Musik *
Buona sera!
Il signore Al Abdullah?
Ich ... äh ... kannte diesen Typen
vorher nicht, aber ...
... ich hatte gehört, dass er
ein richtiger Krimineller ist.
Was hast du denn damals gemacht?
Na ja, mit ... äh ...
mit Geschäften links und rechts.
Ich war damals der Teufel.
Ich war der Teufel.
Ich ... äh ... war hart,
verschwiegen und aggressiv.
Ich habe mit Drogen gehandelt,
die Leute damals beschissen.
Die Leute hatten Angst vor mir.
Auch für die anderen Kriminellen
war ich der Teufel.
Hey! Vieni! Benvenuto!
Benvenuto! Vieni, vieni, vieni!
Tutto bene?
- Ciao!
Io parlo italiano.
- Bravo!
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob du mich nicht verarschst.
Ich dich verarschen?
Willst du mich verarschen?
Hey, wir machen hier Business, okay?
Schau mal: Wenn ich dich verarsche,
bist du in der Kiste.
Wenn du mich verarschst, bin ich in
der Kiste. Du willst etwas machen?
Hast du Angst?
Komm, spielen wir!
Verarschen!
Aspetta!
Ich habe alles gemacht:
Fotos vom Posthof,
Schlüsselausleihe ...
So, ich habe dir eine kleine Skizze
vom Innenhof gemacht.
Siehst du? Genau in dieser Position
sind die Geldkisten, okay?
Was ist mit Securitas? Waffen?
Es gibt keine Waffen.
Hier drin gibt es keine Waffen?
- Nein.
Bist du sicher?
- Ja.
Das Auto, welches das Geld abholt,
kommt ohne Polizei?
Die Postbeamten haben keine Waffen.
Dieser Transport geht ohne Polizei-
schutz, ohne Waffen hin und her -
in der Schweiz, wo eigentlich
alles Geld so sicher ist.
Ihr habt vier Minuten.
Vier Minuten, okay?
Okay!
Und wo ist dieser Schlüssel?
Sehr gut!
Du hast deinen Teil gemacht.
Und jetzt bin ich dran.
Hey, wir ziehen das durch.
Aspetta! Das Allerwichtigste:
Zerstöre diese Fotos, okay?
- Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Hey!
Hallo!
- Hallo!
Schläft der Kleine schon?
Du weisst doch,
dass er um 20 Uhr ins Bett geht.
"'Napoleon',
korrigierte sie ihn ..."
"Napoleon hat gesagt ..."
"Das ist ..."
Ach, hör auf!
Willst du einen Tee?
- Nein, ist gut.
Wie war es bei der Arbeit?
Wir haben
einen super Auftrag bekommen.
Einen sehr grossen Auftrag.
Das müssen wir feiern.
Nein, nein, nein! Der Kleine
schläft. Wecke ihn nicht auf!
Er kann mit uns feiern.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Komm!
Was feiern wir eigentlich?
Der Zukunft.
- D i e  Zukunft.
Das ist mir scheissegal.
* Der Gesang stockt. *
Schon wieder?
* Die Musik stellt ab. *
Scheissanlage!
Kannst du morgen
bitte eine neue kaufen?
Was?
Du spinnst doch!
Und bitte: Schau, dass es keine ...
Kauf die beste, ja?
Meine Relation mit Christina
war sehr gut.
Christina ist eine ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Eine sehr verantwortungsvolle Frau.
Sie schaut zum Haushalt,
sie arbeitet ...
Sie war perfekt.
Ich war der glücklichste Mensch
der Welt.
Ich war viel
mit unserem Sohn zusammen.
Ich kaufte alles für die Wohnung.
Wir hatten das beste Essen, die
besten Möbel, die besten Kleider.
Und Christina musste nie bezahlen.
Ich habe alles
mit meinem Geld bezahlt.
So war es ein kleines Paradies.
Ich war glücklich.
D.h., du hattest Geld.
Ja, ja, ja, ja,
ich hatte Geld, klar.
Vor dem Postraub hatte ich
100'000, 110'000 Fr., ja, ja.
Und was wusste deine Familie
von dem Geld?
Ja, ich hatte ihr gesagt,
ich arbeite im Autobusiness.
Export in den Libanon.
So hat niemand nachgefragt.
Du hast den Überfall
trotz des vielen Geldes gemacht?
Weisst du, Andrea:
Wenn jemand von Millionen spricht,
sind 100'000 nicht so viel.
Das war eine Chance,
die ich nutzen musste.
Ich wusste, eine solche Chance
kommt nur einmal im Leben.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Stimmt es, dass ihr euch immer
auf dem WC getroffen habt?
Ja, ja. Wir haben immer
auf dem WC geredet, das stimmt.
Auf dem WC
haben wir eine Art Büro gemacht.
Wir haben miteinander geredet und
geschaut, dass niemand hereinkommt.
Aber wie hast du
deine Kumpels rekrutiert?
Ah, wir waren damals oft zusammen,
Dieter, Zoran, Hassan und ich.
Wir gingen zusammen in die Disco,
wir haben Sachen gemacht ...
Wir hingen zusammen herum.
Ja, wir waren viel zusammen.
Zuerst Zoran und dann Hassan.
Ihr bleibt hinten im Auto.
Ihr bleibt,
bis ich euch ein Zeichen gebe.
Wenn ich ein Zeichen gebe,
werde ich so machen.
Zoran!
Wie werde ich morgen machen?
Mach keine Scheisse!
Hey, ich sage, wie es läuft, ja?
Ich will nicht, dass morgen
einer eine Scheisse macht!
* Düstere Musik *
Du bist zu spät.
Tutto bene?
Unser Fahrer Silano Domenico.
Hey, morgen aber pünktlich, ja?
Mi raccomando!
Si.
Silano ist ein netter Typ.
Wir gingen ... äh ...
Wir gingen zusammen in die Disco.
Ein paarmal schlief er bei mir.
Domenico war ein ganz ruhiger Mann.
Er war jemand, der zuhörte.
Wenn man ihm etwas sagte, tat er es.
Von A bis Z.
Er war auch sehr korrekt.
Das war Silano.
Wir waren ... äh ...
Ja, er ist ein guter Freund.
Elias war jemand,
der immer Geld und Autos hatte.
Er besuchte Discos und Restaurants -
und das ohne zu arbeiten.
Da musste etwas krumm sein.
Aber ... äh ... was ich ... äh ...
bei Elias gut fand:
Er hatte Herz.
Das ist das Erste,
worauf ich bei einem Menschen achte.
Wenn jemand kein Herz hat,
kann er nie zu meinem Freund werden.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Hassan, der Krieger.
Im Libanon gross und stark geworden.
Dieter, il svizzero.
Die Frauen, ich sage dir:
Verrückt nach ihm!
Wenn ich nur wüsste, weshalb!
Und Zoran, unser Glücksbringer.
Er ist flink wie eine Maus.
Ich habe es gerade erklärt,
aber du weisst ja ...
Si.
- Du bleibst sowieso im Auto.
So!
Das ist der Innenhof.
Hier fahren wir rein.
Die Räuber
hatten es sehr gut geplant.
Ihr bleibt im Auto.
Sie kamen in der Bar
immer wieder zusammen.
Man stellte sich so auf,
dass jeder seinen Job hatte.
Der Insider nahm vorgängig
alles schön mit der Kamera auf.
Die Kisten sind hier.
Das ist die Rampe.
Die Planung war bis dorthin super.
Aber Chef, wir brauchen Waffen.
Nein.
Was?
Ein Überfall ohne Waffen?
Einen Raubüberfall kannst du nicht
mit den Fingern machen.
Also in diesen paar Minuten
musst du dich
wie ein böser Krimineller zeigen.
Waffen? Die Waffen?
Ich habe gesagt:
"Wir nehmen keine Waffen."
"Wir müssen etwas nehmen,
das wie eine richtige Pistole
aussieht, aber keine ist."
Diese haben wir dann gekauft.
Niemand von der Security
war bewaffnet.
Wozu also Waffen?
Okay, Jungs, geht schlafen!
Ab die Post!
* Elias lacht. *
Habt ihr gehört? Ab die Post!
Zoran! Zoran!
Geh nach Hause! Geh etwas essen!
Nicht zu viel! Geh schlafen!
Ich brauche dich morgen, okay?
* Handy *
Hallo?
- Hallo, Gringo!
Können wir das Ding verschieben?
Vielleicht
können wir noch ein bisschen warten.
Was warten? Nichts warten!
Morgen geht's los.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Reden wir vom 1. September,
vom Morgen!
Ich war vorbereitet.
Ich war cool.
Und ich denke,
ich habe meinen Job gemacht.
Hey!
Zeig mal! Zeig mal!
- Gut?
Nicht schlecht.
- Das sieht auch super aus.
Das kannst du verstecken.
Die Kleber hast du?
- Ja.
Marcello hatte uns
die Kleber gebracht.
Wir bereiteten das Auto vor.
Es sah aus wie ein PTT-Auto.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Es ist gut. Es ist perfekt so.
- Aspetta, aspetta.
Noch ein bisschen die Ecken!
- Gehen wir!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das ist gut.
Das ist perfekt.
Gefällt er dir?
- Ja.
Wo hast du ihn her?
- Geheimnis.
Sag schon!
- Nein, ich sage es nicht.
Du musst Dieter und Zoran abholen.
- Ja.
Nachher Hassan.
Si.
Benzin hast du aufgetankt?
- Certo.
Die Batterie?
Kontrolliert? Alles gut?
Natürlich.
Der Seebacherplatz ist gesperrt -
wegen Bauarbeiten.
Du musst hinten durchfahren.
Wie heisst das dort?
Bei der Thurgauerstrasse.
Calmo, hey!
Ich habe die Fahrt geplant, Elias.
- Okay, okay!
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Langsam verstand ich, was passierte.
Ich hatte Angst.
Aber die anderen waren schon bereit.
Sie hatten sich organisiert.
Es gab für mich kein Zurück mehr.
Da kommen sie schon.
Und ich gebe die Befehle!
Wenn Zoran eine Scheisse macht:
Hör nicht auf ihn!
Zoran und Dieter waren wie Brüder.
Sie waren immer zusammen.
Hoffentlich
haben sie nichts vergessen.
Ciao zusammen! Guten Morgen!
Guten Morgen!
- Und?
Gut geschlafen?
Ha, gut geschlafen!
Dieter hat gut geschlafen.
Er hat die ganze Nacht geschnarcht.
Und, Dieter? Wo warst du?
Oben? Unten? Hinten? Vorne?
Halt deine Fresse!
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Da vorne ist Hassan.
Was hat er mitgenommen, dieser ...
Was hat er dabei?
Mann,
das ist ein komischer Typ, Elias!
Was hat er mitgenommen,
dieses Arschloch?
Hassan war mit Elias befreundet,
aber ich habe sie nicht oft
zusammen gesehen.
Ist das dein Ernst?
Was habe ich
wegen der Waffen gesagt?
Du hast gesagt, keine echten Waffen.
Was hat Marcello gesagt?
Chef!
Oh!
- Er hat noch nicht angerufen! Okay?
Ich habe Feuer für dich.
Hattest du Angst?
Angst? Nein.
Nein, ich hatte keine Angst.
Nein, ich war sicher:
Es gibt keine Gewalt.
Das Einzige war:
Wenn die Polizei käme,
müssten wir die Hände hochnehmen
und sagen: "Okay, wir geben auf."
* Düstere Musik *
Alles gut?
- Danke. Ja, ja.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wir hätten schon seit 30 Minuten
oder 60 Minuten
im Innenhof sein müssen.
Aber ... äh ...
Der Transporter ...
Keine Ahnung, ob er Verspätung hatte
oder ... äh ...
Ich hielt es kaum aus.
Ausgerechnet heute
war der Zeitplan anders.
Eines war klar: Wenn der Transporter
nicht hineinfuhr,
würden wir auch nicht hineingehen.
Denn wer weiss, wo das Geld ist?
Hey, ihr wartet, ja?
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
70.
- Okay.
Hey, was glaubst du?
Wie sieht meine Zukunft aus?
* Domenico räuspert sich. *
Ich sehe viel Geld.
Was noch?
- Viele Frauen.
Polizei?
Keine Chance.
Sie haben auf einen Anruf
des Insiders gewartet
und gaben sich eigentlich
sehr normal.
Das zeugt auch
von einer gewissen Unverfrorenheit.
Die jungen Leute würden heute sagen:
"Das war noch cool!"
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich war extrem nervös.
Ich musste ja arbeiten,
so tun, als wäre alles normal.
Aber ich wusste: Jetzt passiert
dann gleich ein Überfall.
Und ich bin schuld.
Hattet ihr denn ein Codewort?
Ja, es war so:
Wenn er "5 Uhr" sagte,
hiess das für uns: "50 Mio."
Wenn er "5.30 Uhr" sagte, also:
"Ich komme um 5.30 Uhr einen Kaffee
trinken", waren es 55 Mio. usw.
* Handy *
6 Uhr - 60 Mio.
Je später, desto besser.
Machen wir Kaffee um 7 Uhr?
Ja, ist gut.
Ich komme um 7 Uhr Kaffee trinken.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
70 Mio., Mann!
Bereit?
Hä?
Jungs?
Bald sind wir reich.
Oder wir sind am Arsch.
Das Blut kommt ...
... kommt wieder hoch.
Adrenalin auch.
Es sind Erinnerungen, die ...
Äh ...
Wenn man darüber redet,
kommt automatisch ...
... alles wieder in den Kopf
und in den Körper.
Dann gingen wir hinein.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Ich musste klingeln.
Natürlich nicht mit dem
Fingerabdruck, sondern mit dem hier.
Ja?
Ciao, mein Freund! Telekom.
Kannst du öffnen, bitte?
Einen Moment!
Es steht etwas im Weg.
Unser Chef hat angerufen.
Wir müssen nur kurz abladen.
Du kannst dann
den Kaffee weitertrinken.
Einen Moment!
Also das Sicherheitskonzept war so:
Wenn der Geldumschlag fällig war,
machte man eine Schleuse.
Und auf der anderen Seite des Hofs
war der Ausgang.
Auch dort
liess man das Gittertor runter.
Und dann war man praktisch geschützt
und man sorgte dafür,
dass niemand anders im Hof war
als diejenigen, die mit
dem Geldumschlag etwas zu tun haben.
Was ist los?
- Die Telekom-Kollegen müssen rein.
Nein, niemanden reinlassen,
wenn wir hier sind!
Fahr zurück, damit sie reinkommen!
- Nein, nicht reinlassen!
Kannst du bitte öffnen?
- Ich kann sie nicht warten lassen.
Kollege, wir sind da
und müssen rein. Keine Zeit!
Der Mann an der Schleuse
machte einen klaren Fehler:
Er hätte unter keinen Umständen
öffnen dürfen.
Er wollte ... äh ...
der gute Kumpel sein.
Die PTT und die Telekom
waren eine Firma.
Und wenn derjenige von der Telekom
sagt: "Tu nicht so blöd!"
"Lass mich rein!",
sagt er vielleicht:
"Ja, ja, er ist ja einer von uns",
und lässt ihn rein.
Er merkt nicht,
dass das viel zu vertrauensselig ist
und man das
in einem Sicherheitsbereich
unter keinen Umständen machen darf.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
* Domenico räuspert sich. *
Es geht los.
Elias?
* Freizeichen *
Hallo!
Andrea? Hallo!
* Piepsen *
* Hektische Musik *
Überfall! Komm aus dem Auto!
Komm aus dem Auto!
Keine Bewegung! Keine Bewegung!
Überfall!
Was ist los?
Alle da rüber! Los! Alle da rüber!
Kommt! Macht mal!
Da sind die Kisten!
Eine Minute!
Keine Bewegung!
Schnell, schnell,
schnell, schnell, schnell!
Keine Bewegung!
Los, los, los! Zoran! Die zweite!
Hol die zweite! Hol die zweite!
Schnell, schnell, schnell!
Elias?
Elias? Hallo?
Was passierte als Erstes,
als ihr in diesem Innenhof wart?
Ähm ...
Also es war so:
Wir fuhren hinein
und parkierten das Auto.
Und ... äh ...
Ich stieg als Erster aus.
Und es war einfach.
Ich stieg aus,
ging nicht mal zwei Meter,
da kamen schon die Leute
mit dem Geld raus.
Wie abgemacht.
Ich kam und das Geld kam raus.
Und ja, dann gab ich den Kollegen
ein Zeichen,
dass sie
aus dem Auto rauskommen sollten.
Aber die Tür war geschlossen.
Und in diesem Moment höre ich,
wie Hassan anfängt,
gegen die Tür zu schlagen.
Bum! Bum!
Komm her!
Dann ging die Tür auf.
Sie war kaputt.
Und Hassan kommt raus.
Wie ein Wahnsinniger.
Und er schreit:
"Niemand bewegt sich! Auf den Boden!
Alle auf den Boden!"
Keine Bewegung! Hier! Auf den Boden!
Alle auf den Boden!
Wäre ich nicht ein Komplize gewesen,
hätte ich wegen seiner Aktion
garantiert sicher Angst gehabt.
Sagen wir es so.
Und ihr habt keine Masken getragen?
Nein, niemand trug eine Maske, nein.
Nein, denn wir wussten,
dass ... äh ...
Marcello sagte,
die Kamera sei abgeschaltet.
Und wir dachten,
wenn die Leute Angst haben
und schockiert sind,
vergessen sie die Gesichter
nach fünf Minuten sowieso.
Daher gingen wir ohne Masken rein.
* Düstere Musik *
Plötzlich ... Ja ...
Es ...
Ja, es gab draussen riesigen Lärm.
Und ... äh ...
Ich sah dann mal ...
... aus dem Fenster.
Mein Fenster war offen.
Ich schrie hinaus: "Hey,
was ist los? Was ist passiert?"
Und in dem Moment
sah ich einen von uns vorbeigehen,
und hinter ihm
war jemand mit einer Pistole.
Da hörte ich irgendwie:
"Keine Bewegung! Überfall!"
- "Hey! Keine Bewegung!"
Ich habe sozusagen
auch Angst bekommen.
Ich dachte: "Wenn es draussen
eine Schiesserei gibt ..."
"... bin ich vielleicht auch dran."
Ich ging feige aus dem Raum
und ging nach hinten.
Keine Bewegung! Alle auf den Boden!
Aber Hassan hatte eine Waffe, oder?
Ja.
Hassan hatte eine Waffe,
die wie eine Kalaschnikow war.
Lass diese!
- Keine Bewegung!
Die Postangestellten
gingen davon aus,
dass das alles echte Waffen waren,
sonst hätten sie sich
nicht so verhalten.
Sie werden auch so ausgebildet,
dass man sich gegen
bewaffnete Gegner nicht wehren soll.
Überfall! Das ist ein Überfall!
Komm aus dem Wagen!
Ich habe gehört, wie der andere
die Ladebewegung machte.
Darum nahm man an,
es seien echte Waffen.
Wäre sie aus Plastik gewesen,
hätte man das gehört.
Es war u.a.
auch eine Kalaschnikow dabei.
Man weiss ja, was mit so einer Waffe
angerichtet werden kann.
War das keine echte Kalaschnikow?
Nein, nein,
das war eine Spielzeugwaffe.
Ganz sicher?
Sicher!
Das regte uns fast am meisten auf.
Spielzeugwaffen!
Wir dachten, es seien echte Waffen.
Diese Waffen waren echt.
Für mich waren sie echt.
Sie gingen sicher nicht
mit Spielzeugwaffen rein.
Ich weiss, alle Leute denken,
die Waffe sei echt gewesen,
aber das war sie nicht.
Meine auch nicht.
Alle am Boden.
Die Kisten waren auf den Rampen.
Silano, hilf!
- Zweite Kiste!
Silano!
* Hektische Musik *
Die letzte Kiste!
Ich selber lud zwei Kisten auf.
Noch eine Minute!
Die schwerste
liess ich auf der Rampe.
Sie war zu schwer. Ich dachte,
es seien eh nur Münzen drin.
Ja,
es könnte auch Gold gewesen sein.
Sie mussten dann aber feststellen,
dass ihr Fiat Fiorino ein bisschen
zu klein für alle Kisten war.
Daher liessen sie tatsächlich
zwei Kisten zurück.
Hätten wir Zeit gehabt, hätte ich
irgendjemanden dort gelassen,
um die Kisten zu bringen
und aufzuladen.
Wir hatten keine Zeit mehr.
Okay! Einsteigen!
Nach vorne! Wir müssen gehen! Zoran!
Los! Rein!
Schnell, schnell, schnell!
Hassan!
- Komm!
Abfahren, Hassan! Wir gehen!
Die Polizei sagt, ihr hättet Chloro-
form und Kabelbinder dabeigehabt.
Ja, Klebeband hatten wir dabei.
Wir hatten gedacht, wir müssten die
Hände der Postangestellten binden.
Aber es ging alles so einfach,
dass wir das gar nicht brauchten.
Der letzte Moment - das waren
nur ein paar Sekunden - war,
als Elias mit seinem Schlüssel
dieses Tor öffnen musste.
Und in diesem Moment dachte ich:
"Das Tor zum Paradies
wurde geöffnet."
Sie fuhren zur Post hinaus.
Warte, warte, warte!
* Reifenquietschen *
Innerhalb von drei Minuten,
weniger als vier Minuten.
Und das war eben die Zeit,
welche die Polizei brauchte.
Es gab noch eine Verzögerung,
denn bis der Erste wirklich
die Telefonnummer 117 wählte,
war leider zu viel Zeit vergangen.
Mir wurde noch vorgeworfen,
dass ich den Alarmknopf
nicht gedrückt hatte.
Erstens war er nicht in meiner Nähe,
und zweitens
war eigentlich schon alles gelaufen.
Die Polizei war ja dann da.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Okay! Hey!
Ich konnte sie vom Fenster an meinem
Arbeitsplatz beobachten und tat so,
als würde ich nichts bemerken.
Was ist los?
Was machen die?
Mein Kollege rief:
"Hey, da passiert ein Überfall!"
Ich sagte: "Das kann nicht sein."
Sie schrien während des Überfalls
derart herum ...
Die hatten vorher Koks genommen.
Warte, warte, warte!
* Reifenquietschen *
Nicht so schnell, Silano!
Nicht so schnell!
Was ist?
- Haltet die Kiste!
Hey, hey, hey!
* Schluchzen *
Oh! Hey! Hey!
Vieni! Was ist los?
Komm raus! Komm schon!
Alles gut! Alles gut! Ruhig!
Vieni! Vieni! Vieni!
* Dramatische Musik *
Und wer hat eigentlich
diese Fotos verloren?
Fotos?
Die habe ich bei mir gehabt.
Ich trug sie bei mir
in einer schwarzen Mappe,
aber ... äh ...
Ich weiss nicht,
wo ich sie verloren habe -
ob beim Aussteigen aus dem Auto oder
beim Rausspringen, keine Ahnung.
Ich drehte mich um.
Ich sehe Hassan
mit der Kalaschnikow,
die er immer noch in der Hand hält.
Sie war sichtbar.
Ich sagte: "Hassan,
denkst du, du seist im Libanon?"
"Hier gibt es keinen Krieg.
Es ist vorbei."
"Bitte leg diese Kalaschnikow weg!"
Nicht so schnell! Nicht so schnell!
Du fühlst dich ... äh ... wie ...
... wie ein Vogel.
Ich meine, du kannst fliegen
und machen, was du willst.
Du hast Geld.
Du kannst Frauen haben,
dir ein Haus kaufen,
Autos, jenste Autos, Schmuck und ...
Ja.
* Sirenen *
Sirenen, Mann.
Ja.
Was dachtest du denn in dem Moment?
- In diesem Moment?
In diesem Moment
hörte ich Radionachrichten.
Sie berichteten bereits
über den Überfall.
Wir hörten die Sirenen
der Polizeiautos.
* Sirenen *
(Radio) Breaking news!
Offenbar eine grössere Geschichte.
Die Fraumünsterpost wurde gestürmt.
Die Stadtpolizei
ist mit einem Grossaufgebot vor Ort.
Ich bekam einen Anruf
der Einsatzzentrale.
Ein bewaffneter Raubüberfall.
Eine ganz grosse Geschichte.
Ein Überfall
auf die Fraumünsterpost.
Ich rückte an den Ereignisort,
den Tatort, aus.
Ich verschaffte mir mal ein Bild.
Sehr schnell wussten wir,
dass 70 Mio. vorbereitet waren.
Wie viel Geld sie mitgenommen
hatten, mussten wir erst zählen.
Meine erste Handlung war, dass ich
bei den Leuten kurz nachfragte,
was genau abgelaufen war.
Ich fragte,
ob es irgendwelche Videoanlagen gab
und ob etwas
aufgezeichnet worden war.
Es gab Leute dort drin,
die man
fast ärztlich behandeln musste,
weil sie einen solchen Schock
erlitten hatten.
Sie konnten sogar
nicht einmal mehr etwas sagen.
Er fuhr sehr schnell.
Ich weiss noch, wie ich sagte:
"Nicht so schnell fahren,
sonst fallen wir der Polizei auf!"
Nach ungefähr fünf Minuten
waren wir schon in der Garage.
* Düstere Musik *
Hattest du
noch eine zweite Waffe im Auto?
Ja.
Ja, ich hatte
eine zweite Pistole dabei, ja.
Und diese war echt und geladen?
Ja.
Aber diese Waffe
war nicht für den Postraub.
Ich sage dir jetzt die Wahrheit.
Das ist eine ...
Okay.
Weisst du, wir sind ...
Es ist viel Geld.
Wir sind viele Leute.
Und ...
Jemand will das Geld
vielleicht alleine.
Okay! Hey!
Finger weg von den Kisten!
Hat jemand von euch
eine Waffe dabei?
Was ist los mit dir?
- Das ist los!
Ob jemand von euch eine Waffe
dabei hat, habe ich gefragt!
Nein.
- Okay, ich will sehen! Ausziehen!
Hey! Hassan, mach keine Scheisse!
* Ladegeräusch *
Hassan!
Ausziehen!
Alle ausziehen, habe ich gesagt!
Ich will sehen, dass keiner von euch
eine Waffe hat. Ausziehen!
Hier sind Kleider.
Nehmt diese Kleider hier!
Legt die anderen Kleider dorthin!
Los!
Silano, du auch. Ausziehen!
Ausziehen, habe ich gesagt!
Gib das her!
Gib, gib, gib, gib, gib!
Hier! Ausziehen!
Du bist ein Stück Scheisse, Elias!
Also d.h., du hättest echt
auf deine Kumpels geschossen?
Ja.
Sagen wir's so: Ich ... äh ...
Ich wäre bereit gewesen,
in den Fuss oder so zu schiessen.
Nicht oben. Nicht oben.
Weisst du, Andrea:
Wenn sie vor so viel Geld stehen,
vor so viel Geld,
drehen die Menschen durch.
Vielleicht will jemand
plötzlich alles alleine. Das ist so.
Das ist wirklich so.
Bei der Mafia ist das so.
Und deshalb wollte ich
auch nicht zur Dago-Bar fahren.
Ich hatte Angst,
dass dort vielleicht ein paar ...
... Leute der Mafia auf uns warten.
Ich hatte wirklich Angst,
dass jemand eine Scheisse macht.
Die Unterhosen kannst du anbehalten.
Nehmt die Kleider! Ist gut.
Aber das musst du mir erklären:
Wie kommt es, dass du
offenbar niemandem vertraut hast?
Schau mal, ich habe mit 17 Jahren
meine Familie verlassen.
Ich ging nach Europa, nach
Frankreich, Spanien, Portugal ...
Ohne Papiere.
Nur mit einem Rucksack.
Ich hatte niemanden.
Ich ... äh ...
... hatte nichts.
Ich musste alles selber entscheiden.
Ich hatte niemanden, der mir sagte,
was richtig und was falsch ist.
Ja, und in dieser Zeit
war mein Vater ohne Arbeit.
Ich habe vier Schwestern
und einen Bruder.
Grossmutter und Grossvater
lebten auch noch.
Ich musste Geld schicken,
damit 18 Personen leben konnten.
Die Cousinen waren auch dort.
Ich habe nie Hilfe bekommen -
von niemandem.
Und ...
Wenn es so ist, ist es einfach,
dass du vielleicht
auf die falsche Strasse kommst.
Wenn du siehst, dass es einfach ist,
mit Drogen Geld zu verdienen ...
Hey, was ist los?
Ihr seht super aus.
Hey, was ist los? Mach auf, Dieter!
Mach die Kiste auf! Komm!
Hey! Alles gut, Mann! Wir machen
jetzt die Scheisskiste auf!
Hoffentlich
sind nicht nur Münzen drin.
Halt die Klappe mit deinen Münzen,
Mann! Mach auf, Mann! Mach auf!
* Popmusik *
Ha!
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp!
Hassan!
Nimm das! Ich gebe ... Moment!
Ich gebe das Geld, okay?
Okay, kommt! Hassan, komm zu mir!
Komm zu mir!
10 ...
... 20 ...
Na ja, 53 Mio. -
das ist sehr viel Geld.
Das ist ein Betrag,
bei dem es auch für den Kreispost-
direktor fast unvorstellbar ist,
dass man so etwas klauen kann.
Hassan, ich bringe dich um, Mann!
40. Abfahren!
So! Zwei ...
Die nächste Frage war dann:
"Wollen wir das sagen?"
Und für mich war der Entscheid
von Anfang an klar:
Man nennt von Anfang an
den richtigen Betrag.
Wenn die Dimensionen mal klar sind,
kommt man auch auf diese Details.
Silano! Finger weg!
Und 40!
Zwei! Mach auf!
Vier! Zehn!
* Jubel *
Jeder fühlte sich wie:
"Ich bin jetzt der König!"
Und ich schaue sie an und denke:
"Sie werden schnell erwischt."
Viel Glück zusammen!
- Ein schönes Leben! Mach's gut!
Sie waren zu einem grossen Teil
sehr gut vorbereitet -
bis zu dem Moment,
als sie in ihrem Unterschlupf waren.
Dann war da
einfach diese riesige Menge Geld.
Jeder bekam einen riesigen Anteil
und zottelte
mit mindestens 4 Mio. ab.
Es war noch nicht vorbei.
Wir hatten uns
noch nicht mal davongemacht.
Wenn wir irgendetwas falsch machten,
würde die Polizei schnell kommen.
Hey!
Hast du mir etwas Geld
für ein Billett?
Danke! Merci! Geiler Kerl!
Mimmo? Mimmo!
Kannst du schauen,
dass das Auto nachher verschwindet?
Also: Du hattest 53 Mio.
Minus die 16 Mio., die du
an deine Komplizen verteilt hattest.
D.h., du hattest noch 37 Mio.
für dich.
37 Mio. - ja, das ist richtig.
* Orientalische Popmusik *
Und was hast du dann gemacht?
- Ich rief meine Freundin an.
Sie fragte: "Was ist los?"
Ich sagte: "Kommen, nicht fragen!"
"Und bring die Reisekoffer mit!"
Dann kam sie.
Wir füllten die Koffer mit Geld.
Und den Rest
stopften wir in die Babytasche.
Christina nahm das Baby
und steckte es in die Babytasche.
Alles ins Auto.
Das Baby schlief wieder ein.
Dann fuhren wir so davon.
Das Baby schlief auf Millionen -
im Alter von einem Monat.
Also, du hattest 37 Mio.
37 Mio. - ja, das ist richtig.
Genau. Und ... ähm ...
Wir fuhren ... äh ...
Wir fuhren nach Dübendorf.
Und bei der Autobahnausfahrt
Dübendorf stand die Polizei.
Christina fährt,
ich sitze neben ihr,
unser Sohn ist auf dem Rücksitz.
Und ich denke:
"Oh mein Gott, die Polizei!"
Aber zum Glück
haben sie uns nicht aufgehalten.
Und so trug ich die Koffer
in meine Wohnung.
Die Koffer waren schwer,
nehme ich an.
Sehr, sehr schwer.
Aber ja, die Motivation war gross.
So habe ich ...
Ich ging die Treppe hinauf
wie eine Feder.
Und dann haben wir
eine Flasche Champagner geöffnet
und uns Zigarren angezündet.
Dann rief ich sofort
einen Mitwisser an.
Ich sagte:
"Da sind 14 Mio. für Marcello,
2 Mio. sind für dich."
Mir blieben 21 Mio.
Das war mein Geld.
Ich bin der Boss.
Ich habe das organisiert.
Ich habe die Leute bezahlt. Punkt.
(Originalkommentar)
Über 53 Mio. Fr. Beute
bei einem Überfall
auf die Zürcher Fraumünsterpost.
Gewaltiger Medienaufmarsch
heute Abend um 17 Uhr
vor der Zürcher Fraumünsterpost.
Im In- und Ausland ist das Interesse
am grössten Postraub aller Zeiten
gross.
Ein Fall für Hollywood,
der Tatort liegt aber in Zürich.
Im bisher grössten Postraub
der Schweiz
entwenden dreiste Diebe
über 53 Mio. Fr.
Die Täter verschwanden spurlos.
Meine Frau und ich waren in Malaysia
in den Ferien gewesen.
Morgens um 6 Uhr
landeten wir in Kloten.
Und dann war ganz atypisch
die Cousine meiner Frau dort
und holte uns ab.
Und die erste Reaktion war:
"Ist etwas passiert?"
In Zürich kann man 53 Mio. Fr.
ganz einfach mitnehmen -
und das alles bei der Post.
So einfach geht das.
Das gibt einen Schlag in den Magen.
Also das ist ...
Das ist ... äh ... Das ist ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Das ist der Gau.
Genau dort bei der Ausfahrt kam
ein weisses Auto herausgefahren -
ziemlich schnell.
Es quietschte. Ich schaute hin.
Sonst achtete niemand gross darauf.
Sie fuhren wie die Irren davon.
Ich ging wieder rein und sagte,
es habe wohl einen Überfall gegeben,
aber nur aus Jux. Wir lachten.
Wenig später kam die Polizei.
Dann fanden wir bald mal heraus,
dass es doch kein Witz war.
(Originalkommentar)
Der Überfall schien minutiös geplant.
Die Täter
mussten das Sicherheitssystem
und den Zeitpunkt des Geldtransports
gekannt haben.
Man hatte so viele Sicherheits-
vorkehrungen spielend überwunden.
Es war
einfach derart gutes Wissen da,
dass für uns sehr schnell klar war:
Ohne Insider ging es nicht.
Dann mussten wir
nur noch diesen Insider ermitteln.
Ein leichter Verdacht ...
... kommt sofort.
Ich sage mir:
"Wie kann das sonst passieren?"
"Wer kann dieses Tor sonst öffnen?
Jemand muss involviert sein."
Und dann hiess es plötzlich:
Wer etwas gesehen habe,
solle sich melden.
Da dachte ich: "Na gut!"
und meldete mich.
Und man musste dann
mit einem Polizeiauto,
das nicht angeschrieben war,
zur Polizeiwache fahren -
mit einigen anderen zusammen.
Jeder Einzelne ging ...
... in ein Büro und wurde vernommen.
Am nächsten Tag
holten mich zwei zivile Polizisten
am Arbeitsplatz ab.
Ich wusste:
"Jetzt kommt das Verhör."
Das machten sie mit allen.
Ich war deshalb ganz ruhig
und ging mit.
"Wir müssen Sie befragen."
"Kommen Sie bitte mit!"
So freundlich sprachen sie mit mir.
Mit einem roten Ford
brachten sie mich zur Hauptwache.
Wie lange
arbeiten Sie schon bei der Post?
Seit Juli 1995.
Und wo haben Sie
bei der PTT angefangen?
Direkt bei der Fraumünsterpost.
Schildern Sie mir doch mal den
Tagesablauf am Tag des Überfalls!
Der Tagesab... Also ...
Es war zunächst ein normaler Tag.
Ich musste jede Einzelheit erzählen,
die am Tag des Überfalls
aufgefallen war.
Ob sich jemand seltsam benahm usw.
Lärm? Äh ... Wo?
Im Hof.
Innenhof.
- Ah, ja.
Die Stimmung
war natürlich himmeltraurig.
Jeder verdächtigte den anderen:
War es derjenige? War es der andere?
Wenn man einander
nicht mehr vertrauen kann
und jeder
ein potenzieller Gangster ist,
können Sie nicht mehr arbeiten.
Na ja, ich wusste, dass ...
... ich nichts gemacht hatte.
Ich war drinnen bei der Arbeit.
Aber ich dachte, vielleicht könnte
ich trotzdem verdächtigt werden ...
... da irgendwie
mitgemischt zu haben.
Wo waren Sie,
und was sahen Sie im Hof?
Na ja, es ist einfach. Also ...
Dann musste ich
eine Zeichnung vom Innenhof machen.
Da verstellte ich extra
meine Schrift.
Ich zeichnete die Rampe
und die Garage -
immer ein bisschen falsch,
damit es nicht auffiel.
Und ich bin gegenüber -
also hier, im zweiten Stock.
Ich machte brav alles,
was sie wollten,
und erklärte dazu.
Come si dice? Äh ...
Un camion.
- Lieferwagen?
Genau.
Aber derjenige mit dem Geld.
Die Zeichnungen für die anderen
hatte ich ja für Elias gemacht.
Also musste diese Zeichnung
anders aussehen. Klar, oder?
... zu Boden gedrückt.
Ich dachte: "Was ist los?"
- Das haben Sie alles gesehen?
Ja, klar. Und dann dachte ich,
ich müsse helfen.
Dann gingen wir schnell
die Treppe nach unten ...
Haben Sie mit dem Überfall
etwas zu tun?
Nein ... äh ... gar nichts.
Gut. Danke.
Danke.
Daraufhin
konnte man schon feststellen,
dass ein Teil der Bevölkerung
sich noch freute,
dass der Post so etwas passiert war.
Es gab ja auch
keine Personenschäden.
Und man sagte:
"Wie kann man so blöd sein
und denen 53 Mio. schenken?"
Wahnsinn!
Ja, wahnsinnig.
Niemand wurde verletzt.
Ich finde es noch gut.
Ja, das ist katastrophal verrückt!
Schön für diejenigen, die es haben.
Die Posträuber
waren sozusagen die Helden.
Es ging ja nur um Geld.
Es wurde ja niemand umgebracht.
Und wir waren sozusagen die Dummen,
die dort standen
und es nicht verhindern konnten,
oder?
Für mich waren sie nie
in irgendeiner Form Helden.
Sie waren Täter, Kriminelle,
denen ein Coup gelungen war.
Das waren wirklich Gangster.
* Düstere Musik *
Hallo?
- Elias, hallo.
Hallo.
Hattest du eine Idee, was du
mit den 21 Mio. machen würdest?
Ja, meine Idee war, zunächst einmal
nach Brasilien zu fliegen,
an die Copacabana.
Und dann wollte ich in den Libanon,
um ein Geschäft zu eröffnen.
Eine Diskothek oder so
oder ein Casino.
Ich wollte ein grosses Geschäft
eröffnen
und dann wie ein König
am Meer sitzen.
Aber leider kam es nicht dazu.
(Originalkommentar) Die Ermittlungen
im Postraub kommen voran.
Bruno Kaiser
hat am Morgen des Jahrhundertraubs
zwei Tätern
den berühmten Espresso serviert.
Als ich den Kaffee servierte,
wusste ich es noch nicht.
Aber als der eine
dann durch die Sihl-Pforte
bzw. durch die Fraumünster-Pforte
fuhr,
nahm ich es an, weil er ja vorher
bei mir gewesen war
und mit diesem Auto wegfuhr -
mit quietschenden Reifen.
Man reagierte sofort, als der Zeuge
der Polizei das erzählte.
Wir sammelten diese Kaffeetassen
sofort ein.
Und tatsächlich
waren Fingerabdrücke darauf.
Was glaubst du,
wie sieht meine Zukunft aus?
Gerade vom Haupttäter hatten wir
Fingerabdrücke und wussten,
wer es war.
Aufgrund dessen setzte man bei ihm
eine Observation an.
Ich sprach mit meiner Freundin.
Wir fanden keinen Platz
für das Geld.
Und ...
Dann fuhren wir zur Wohnung
einer Freundin von ihr.
Sie hat nichts mit dem Raub zu tun.
Sie ist eine anständige Frau.
Äh ... Wir versteckten das Geld
bei ihr im Schrank - 18 Mio.
Wir dachten, niemand käme auf
die Idee, dass das Geld bei ihr sei.
Wir kontrollierten die Telefone.
Wir machten Abklärungen im Umfeld,
wer mit wem verbandelt war.
Man ermittelte Freundinnen,
man ermittelte Wohnorte.
Man installierte die Mikrofone
am richtigen Ort
oder Wanzen an einem Auto.
Wir fingen dann an, mitzuhören
und stellten auch fest,
dass da eine Reise geplant war
und auch durchgeführt wurde -
z.B. vom Chef mit seiner Entourage
nach Mailand.
Direkt Hotel Milano.
Dort nahmen wir eine Suite.
Wir besuchten den Dom und Versace.
Ich habe dort super Kleider gekauft.
Und ich wechselte dann
ein bisschen italienisches Geld.
Ich hatte vom Raub etwas Geld
mitgenommen: 80'000 oder so.
Ich wartete darauf, dass
die Freundin mit ihrem Freund kommt.
Und dass sie mit Geld kommen.
- Mit 18 Mio.?
Das war der Plan.
(Originalkommentar)
Da steht den Posträubern
die Welt mit all ihren Verlockungen
offen.
Doch es mit vollen Händen ausgeben:
Würden sie da nicht auffallen?
Es ist sicher so, dass es jetzt
eine extreme Stresssituation ist,
denn jetzt fängt das Schwierige
im Prinzip an.
Was genau sie machen,
wie sie es machen,
entscheidet schlussendlich darüber,
ob man sie erwischt.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Innerhalb der Stadt Zürich war
die Stadtpolizei sehr gut vernetzt.
Und uns wurden sehr schnell
Sachen zugänglich gemacht,
die normalerweise
viel länger dauern.
Wir bekamen auch sehr schnell
Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung.
Wir bekamen im weitesten Sinne
Hinweise von Leuten aus der Szene.
(Originalkommentar)
Razzia in der Dago-Bar in Seebach.
Es wurden Leute verhaftet,
doch von den Haupttätern
ging niemand ins Netz.
Ich war zufällig 50, 100 m entfernt
vom Spielsalon.
Und ich konnte alles sehen,
was die Polizei machte.
Ja, da dachte ich:
"Ich muss weg von hier!"
Gleichentags ging ich weg.
Das war eine schwierige Zeit
nach dem Überfall.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen -
v.a., wenn man solche Angst hat:
Ich wusste nicht,
was mit meinem Anteil passiert war.
Ob mein Vertrauensmann
das Geld wirklich bekommen hatte.
Ich konnte das ja
noch nicht kontrollieren.
Ich konnte mit niemandem
Kontakt aufnehmen.
Wir haben Beweise dafür,
dass Sie an der Vorbereitung des
Raubüberfalls vom 1. September 1997
aktiv teilgenommen haben.
Wir wissen,
dass Sie an Ihrem Arbeitsort
Fotoaufnahmen gemacht haben.
Wann ... äh ... war das?
Das müssten Sie
doch eigentlich wissen.
Es kann sein. Äh ... Ich habe ...
... mehrere Male
Fotos in der Post gemacht.
Ich habe diese Fotos
für meine Kollegen gemacht.
Für welche Kollegen
haben Sie diese Fotos gemacht?
Ich habe so Karten,
wie Postkarten, gemacht.
Und ich habe sie
meiner Familie in Italien geschickt.
Ich weiss, dass Sie auch im August,
also unmittelbar vor dem Überfall,
Fotos gemacht haben.
Das stimmt nicht.
Aber wir haben Beweise dafür.
Es kann sein.
Ich habe viele Fotos.
Das ist für mich wie ein Hobby.
Aber was hat das
mit dem Überfall zu tun?
Ich fordere Sie nochmals auf,
die Wahrheit zu sagen,
in welcher Form Sie
am Überfall beteiligt waren.
Sie können mich die ganze Nacht
dazu befragen.
Ich habe nichts damit zu tun.
Wem haben Sie die Fotos gegeben?
Niemandem!
Ich mache so etwas nicht.
Ich ...
... möchte selber Polizist werden.
Eine Karriere als Polizist
können Sie bei Ihrem Leumund
vergessen.
Haben Sie noch etwas hinzuzufügen?
* Düstere Musik *
Man verhaftete ihn nicht sofort,
weil man ganz sicher sein musste,
dass er der Insider war,
aber man observierte
natürlich auch ihn und schaute,
mit wem er Kontakt hatte
und wo sie sich trafen.
Irgendwann
hatten wir so viel zusammen,
dass sich der Tatverdacht gegen ihn
derart verdichtete ...
Einen ganz wichtigen Punkt
hatten wir,
als ein Polizeioffizier
irgendwann sagte:
"Jetzt seht euch dieses Foto an!"
"Auf diesem Foto ist ein markantes
Auto und im Hintergrund eine Uhr."
"Wenn wir die Aufnahmen der Post
nehmen,
zurückgehen und dieses Auto
und diese Uhr wieder suchen,
kommen wir irgendwann
zu dem Zeitpunkt,
als dieses Foto gemacht wurde,
das wir vor uns haben."
Und da war dann natürlich
bei der Person, die das gewesen war,
sehr naheliegend, dass das
der Insider gewesen sein musste.
Haben Sie Aufnahmen im Innenhof
der Fraumünsterpost gemacht,
von den Sicherheitseinrichtungen?
Ich möchte zuerst Ihre Beweismittel
sehen, bevor ich antworte.
Erkennen Sie die Person,
die mit einer Kamera im Innenhof
der Fraumünsterpost Aufnahmen macht?
Ich erkenne mich selbst
auf diesem Foto.
Ich brauche eine Pause.
* Düstere Musik *
In diesem Moment wusste ich ...
... dass ich
keine Chance mehr hatte -
nicht nur wegen der Fotos.
Ich hatte ja auch keine Ahnung,
was mit den anderen passiert war.
Ich wusste auch nicht,
ob sie mich verraten würden.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Haben Sie diese Informationen
der Täterschaft zukommen lassen?
Ja.
Das sind Idioten.
Sie meinen die Leute,
für die Sie die Fotos gemacht haben?
Ja.
Haben Sie selbst die Fotos der
Täterschaft zur Verfügung gestellt?
Können ...
Können Sie mir
eine schriftliche Bestätigung geben,
dass ich, wenn ich rede,
nicht für zehn oder 20 Jahre
hinter Gitter bleiben muss?
* Dramatische Musik *
Es war eigentlich
eine Erleichterung,
als sie ihn verhaftet hatten,
als man wusste,
wie das ganze Zeug rausgegangen war.
Der Haupttäter rief dann
von Mailand aus seine Freundin an.
Und diese Freundin ...
... wurde dann gefragt:
"Bist du im Haus oder draussen?"
Dann sagte sie:
"Nein, nein, ich bin drin."
Da wussten wir,
dass wir dorthin fahren mussten.
Und dann kam die Freundin, bei
der wir das Geld versteckt hatten.
Sie kam mit ihrem Freund,
aber ohne Geld.
Sie sagte:
"Weisst du, es ist zu gefährlich."
"Vielleicht
gibt es eine Kontrolle oder so."
Ich habe das Geld
nicht mehr gesehen.
99,99 % der Leute,
die mit viel Geld zu tun haben,
verändern sich.
Wenn du ihm heute vertrauen kannst
und er mit viel Geld Kontakt hat,
herrscht danach kein Vertrauen mehr.
Das ist bei 99,99 % so.
Die Verhaftung
war an einem Nachmittag.
Wir sassen in einem Restaurant.
Ich vergesse diesen Moment nie.
Es war wie in einem Actionfilm.
Wir kamen raus, und da war
die Polizei, die Carabinieri -
alle 180, 190 cm gross.
Überall stehen Alfa Romeo.
Und ich bin nicht sicher,
aber ich glaube,
auch ein Helikopter war da.
Es ging alles sehr schnell.
Ich habe nur noch ...
Ja,
plötzlich war ich in diesem Auto.
(Originalkommentar)
Erfolg für die Polizei in Mailand:
Der Haupttäter des Postraubs
wurde festgenommen.
Die beiden Jungen
im Alter von 20 bzw. knapp 20
hauten zusammen nach Spanien ab.
Sie hatten ihre Beute dabei.
Jemand ging in Marbella zur Polizei
und sagte,
dass zwei Junge
mit Geld um sich geworfen
und Häuser gekauft hätten
und solches Zeug.
(Originalkommentar)
So fand das flotte Leben in Spanien
mit Cüplis und Prostituierten
rasch ein ungemütliches Ende.
Der Posträuber Zoran V.
war mit 1,3 Mio. Fr. und Schmuck
in einer Strassenkontrolle
hängen geblieben.
Ebenfalls ein rasches Ende nahmen
die Spanien-Träume von Dieter M.
Mit seinem Anteil von 4 Mio. Fr.
kaufte er eine Acht-Zimmer-Villa
samt Umschwung.
Als man die ersten Täter
gefasst hatte,
freute ich mich auch.
Ich sagte: "Wenigstens das!"
Ich verspürte
eine gewisse Genugtuung,
dass halt Verbrechen
eben doch kurze Beine haben.
(Originalkommentar)
Dank Tipps von Insidern
konnte die Polizei
die lange Flucht von Hassan beenden.
Er wurde in Berlin verhaftet.
Damit sind nun fünf
der sechs Täter gefasst.
Noch einer, dann sind
alle Posträuber von Zürich gefasst.
Bei diesem einen handelt es sich
um den 24-jährigen Italiener
Domenico Silano.
Von Rom flog ich ... äh ...
nach Venezuela.
Nach einer Woche,
als ich die Situation
in Venezuela gesehen hatte ...
Was hatte ich gesehen?
Zu viel Kriminalität.
Ich entschied mich für Miami.
Äh ...
Ich kannte in Miami keinen Menschen.
Und ... äh ...
Mit der Zeit
vermisste ich meine Freundin.
Als Italiener ist einem die Familie
natürlich wichtig.
Äh ...
Das Umfeld mit den Leuten, mit denen
man zusammen war, ist wichtig.
Man meldet sich halt.
Das alles führte dazu,
dass wir immer genauer wussten,
wo er sich ungefähr aufhielt.
Ich wusste schon:
Wenn meine Freundin zu mir kommen
würde, wäre meine Flucht beendet.
Hey!
- Ja?
Ich will, dass du weisst ...
... dass ich dich sehr mag.
Und egal, was passiert:
Vergiss das nie, okay?
Sie war eine Woche bei mir.
Einen Monat später rufe ich sie an.
Und sie sagte zu mir:
"Hör zu,
ich war auf dem Polizeiposten."
Und dann frage ich:
"Wie lange warst du dort?"
Sie sagte: "Vier Stunden."
"Okay, alles klar", sagte ich.
"Mach dir keine Sorgen!"
"Bald sehen wir uns."
Meine Freundin
ist absolut keine Verräterin.
Du kannst von einer normalen Frau
nicht verlangen,
dass sie ...
... dass sie nicht
mit der Polizei kooperiert.
Und dann ging man systematisch vor -
in Zusammenarbeit
mit der örtlichen Polizei in Miami.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Man fragte einerseits Strasse
um Strasse, Block um Block nach ihm.
Man beschrieb ihn.
Man sagte:
"Wir suchen diese Person."
"Habt ihr sie irgendwo gesehen?"
Und irgendwann kommt er um die Ecke.
Da war sofort der Helikopter
auf dem Haus, alles war umstellt.
Man wusste nicht,
ob er bewaffnet war oder nicht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich konnte in einem Artikel lesen,
dass 500 Polizisten
eingesetzt worden waren.
Oder 200.
Ein paar Hundert auf jeden Fall.
Äh ... Meine Wohnung ...
Also um meine Wohnung herum
waren nur Polizisten.
Also ich konnte nicht abhauen.
Und dann verhafteten sie ihn dort.
Es sind jetzt alle
mutmasslichen Posträuber verhaftet.
Und alle geben zu, am Postraub
beteiligt gewesen zu sein.
Wie sieht es mit Ihrer
persönlichen Zufriedenheit aus?
Sehen Sie mich an! Dann wissen Sie:
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
(Originalkommentar)
Strafmildernd war,
dass beim Raub
nur ungeladene Waffen im Spiel waren,
dass niemand verletzt wurde
und keine ausgekochte Bande
zugeschlagen hatte.
Die riesige Beute von 53 Mio.
verschärfte die Strafe hingegen.
Natürlich wünscht man sich
als Staatsanwalt immer,
dass die Leute aus dem Verfahren,
aus dem Erlebnis Strafverfolgung
etwas lernen,
dass sie etwas mitnehmen
und ihre Zukunft
auf ehrlicher Arbeit aufbauen
und nicht mehr kriminell sind.
Das wünsche ich eigentlich
jedem Beschuldigten,
der eine kriminelle Tat begeht.
Elias, warum wurdest du dann
wieder verhaftet?
Ich flog via Budapest nach Damaskus.
Und am Flughafen
nahmen sie mich fest.
Aber mit welcher Begründung denn?
Spionage.
Das war wegen 1983.
Ich war damals 17 Jahre alt
und lebte im Libanon.
Und die sagen, ich hätte mit
dem Geheimdienst zusammengearbeitet,
aber ... äh ...
ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ich war ... äh ... minderjährig.
Das war nur wegen des Geldes.
Sie sagen: "Du hast Geld
aus der Schweiz mitgenommen."
"Wir wollen einen Teil davon."
Das ist der Grund
für diese Verurteilung.
Sie glauben, ich habe Millionen,
aber ... äh ...
... ich habe nichts.
Die Post schrieb bis kurz
vor diesem Überfall ein Defizit.
1996 war das erste Jahr, in dem man
einen minimalen Gewinn machte.
Und dann gehen gleich 23
oder 25 Mio. wieder weg.
Das hat einen schon getroffen.
Ja, und wo ist jetzt
das restliche Geld?
Also mein Geld wurde gefunden:
18 Mio.
Aber du hast gesagt, du hättest
21 Mio. für dich behalten.
Also, ich habe eine Million
nach Italien mitgenommen.
Dieses Geld
nahm mir die Polizei weg.
750'000 habe ich
einem anderen Mitwisser gegeben.
Und dann noch anderen
ein paar Hunderttausend.
Ich habe nichts mehr.
- Du hast vorhin gesagt,
du hättest 80'000
nach Mailand mitgenommen.
Mein Anteil waren 4 Mio.
Und ... ähm ...
Von diesen 4 Mio.
wurde fast eine Million verbraucht -
während meiner Flucht.
Der Rest ist leider ...
äh ... verschwunden.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das Geld
dem Falschen anvertraut.
Es ist leider so.
Aber es ist so.
Ich würde meinen -
aber das ist ungesichert -,
dass die Täter ...
... von dem Geld nicht so viel ge-
sehen haben, als sie draussen waren.
Die Helfer und Helfershelfer
schöpften das Geld allmählich ab.
Sie gaben es aus, verspekulierten es
oder was auch immer.
Das Geld
floss in den Finanzkreislauf ein.
Also da gab es relativ schnell, nach
ein paar Jahren, würde ich sagen,
kein Geld mehr
in irgendeinem Tresor.
Heute geht es mir ziemlich gut.
Ich kann mich ... äh ...
wirklich nicht beklagen.
Heute arbeite ich als Barmann -
in Deutschland.
Jeder ist dort, wo ich arbeite,
herzlich willkommen.
Einfach ... äh ...
... anständig sein.
* Domenico lacht. *
Ich bereue gar nichts.
Gar nichts!
Ich bereue gar nichts!
Ich habe im Verlauf dieser Arbeit,
dieser Recherchen, der Interviews,
von all dem,
was ich mit den Räubern
und auch mit der Polizei
zu tun hatte,
nicht herausgefunden,
warum jemand Polizist
oder Räuber ist.
Aber ich denke,
im Fall dieser Posträuber ...
... sind das alles junge Männer,
die als Kinder oder Jugendliche
eine Art ...
Mir kommen sie vor wie Vögel,
die zu früh
aus dem Nest gefallen sind.
Also sie haben in ihrer Kindheit
oder Jugend
alle
eine Form von Entwurzelung erlebt -
zumindest diejenigen, die ich kenne
und mit denen ich Kontakt hatte.
Das ist sicher keine Entschuldigung
für das,
was sie getan haben,
aber vielleicht ist es
ein Stück weit eine Erklärung.
Wie alt bist du denn jetzt?
Jetzt bin ich 54 Jahre alt.
Und die Hälfte meines Lebens
habe ich hinter Gittern verbracht.
Mein Sohn ist in der Schweiz.
Ich habe mit ihm manchmal Kontakt
über WhatsApp.
Ja.
Ich habe alles falsch gemacht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Unheilvolle Musik *
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2020